before we get started into the video I
want to tell you guys that I will be
away for about 5 days so I will not be
making a video during that time I'm
going on vacation with my family so I
will come back from that and make some
more content so hope you guys understand
and I'll see you when I get back let's
get started into the
[Music]
video what is Up Guys in today's video
we will be doing another flipping for an
hour and we will be flipping with 20 mil
and we will be buying items that are in
the the top 100 basically items that are
traded really frequently and so
basically what we're going to be doing
we're going to be checking the margins
buy something high sell it
low and then see the margin so I think
the buy limit on this is like 13,000 so
I'll go ahead and buy that many and then
I checked cannonballs and coal but the
margins aren't as good as I thought
they'd be normally they're really good
you want to
do you want to do ores bars that kind of
stuff because those stuff sell for a lot
so we'll go ahead and check all these
first
and I will start the timer now I forgot
to start it but I'll start it
now so as you can see the shark is a
10gp margin so those are the kind of
items you want to
buy I don't remember what the B limit is
I think it's 6K but I will look it up so
the B limit for sharks is actually I
think it said
10K so I'm going to buy
I'm G to buy this many of
them yeah it's
10K actually I need to buy less of those
cuz I already bought 13 so I don't want
to buy over the limit because I want to
be able to check the margin at the end
if that makes
sense so we'll just do this because I'm
not sure how many I bought but we'll do
this and then another item are raw
sharks that are traded a lot
oh I actually don't have enough for that
I didn't even realize I spent so much
money okay but the steel bars so I can
sell them for
465 so some of the gold bars are coming
in so I need to do some items that don't
cost as much so try
lobsters that's pretty good margin but
I'm going to try something cheaper so I
can figure it out let's try iron
ore cuz I only have almost 2 mil to
spend all right so that margin's not
good either what about raw Lobster
that's okay we're looking for something
better let's try law runes sometimes
runes are good
margins okay so that's a way better
margin um I want to say it's 5K but I
will look it
up oh it's 12K I wasn't even
close so Noti how this margin's like
five so that's a lot
better what did I say it was 9k I
think I mean 12K yeah 12K I don't have
enough money okay we'll buy let's try uh
9k of them nope okay let's try 8 of them
oh
perfect all right now these are selling
and and these are buying these are not
buying so maybe the price has gone up
I'll check that in a little bit okay so
these are all selling so we're about 5
minutes
in and items aren't buying I'm not
undercutting people you can undercut
people and make this a lot faster so I
might start doing that towards the end
so these are buying just bought a
thousand of them but I'm not
undercutting them because so those are
all buying I'm going to try to find an
item while I'm looking what's another
what about death
rune death
runes there a pretty good margin we'll
buy 5K of those I think we should have
enough nope 4K maybe yeah we'll do 4K of
them so these are still
selling these are
buying sharks are slowly buying gold do
are slowly buying so I noticed swordfish
have a good margin so I'm going to go
ahead and buy like
um I bet the by limit is like 9k of
these or something like that no that's
too many okay we'll do
5K can't do that either we'll do 4K of
them so the steel bar
sold so how much money do we make on
that steel bars so
4184 so we made about 30k on that we
could do that again but I'm going to
keep looking so the law runes are almost
sold the death runs are not buying the
sharks are buying a little slow the
swordfish are not buying the gold or is
going a little slow I'm going to go
ahead and end these two the Gold War is
still coming in so I'm going to let that
H lawn runes are almost done so we have
about 4 mil I'll leave those sharks for
a little bit longer we'll
see um I'll come back when I get some
more items so all law runes
fold so I don't okay so 31
231 so we'll put them in for 231 see if
they sell these gold or are almost done
and I'm still looking for some other
items so I'll be back when I find some
more so we put in an offer for some
blood runes for 215 it's about a 5gp
margin so we're going to go ahead and
see if those sell I'm probably going to
start undercutting people because
stuff's not selling so I'll be back when
I find some more items so ironically I
wasn't undercutting anyone but someone
was undercutting me that's why none were
selling so I'll go ahead and put an
offer for these I'm going to undercut
them hopefully I can buy them quicker
these gold ore are almost done and if I
can get those sharks it's going to be a
pretty big
margin and these gold ores are almost
done so I'll be back when those sell so
these sold I actually don't remember how
much gold
ore I don't even know if I have enough
room to buy one okay luckily I did so
323 and I bought him for 320 so we can
sell them for
323 not great margin but better than
nothing and these sharks are buying a
lot faster than now that undercut the
person I hate undercutting but sometimes
you have
to um these blood runes are not buying
so I might have to uncut someone these
law runes are barely selling so we might
check that in a little bit so we put in
some offer for some monkfish I undercut
the person by 1 GP so I don't have
enough money to do anything right now so
I'm going to go ahead and wait a little
bit we're at 15 minutes so we still got
a while so I'll come back with some of
the stuff is selling and buying all
right so these law runes sold pretty
quick and the shark bot so I'm going to
put the sharks in for 1K so a 10gp
margin so that'd be a big one um I want
to check the raw sharks again and maybe
the raw monkfish and some other items
and then I will be be back so I don't
know if it's just a fluke one person
might have done it but I don't know
let's hope it's not there's a huge
margin on Raw monkfish so I undercut him
by one if it stays like this I might
even undercut by a few more GP but let's
hope they buy um these monkfish are
buying slowly the Sharks probably start
selling soon and these gold or selling
kind of slowly so I might change those
prices but I'll be back when I do
something so I changed some of the
prices and everything's moving a little
bit more smoothly we're at 22 minutes
I'm putting in offer for myth bars so
we'll see if those sell cuz they have a
pretty good margin right now it's about
like a six GP margin so we'll see how
that goes um I might move stuff around
again so we'll see so just an update I'm
still buying the mythal bars I'm now
buying raw sharks I got rid of the raw
monkfish and switched them and just
started selling them because none of
them were buying I'm now selling the
monkfish because none of them were
buying the sharks have kind of stopped
selling and the gold has stopped selling
so that's kind of sad so I think I might
put those in for 321 I bought them for
320 so that
sucks so let's hope I don't have to put
them any lower and I think I bought
these for 390 so I will go 9995 I think
that's about as low as I'll go because
they should shell they should they
should sell anyways so everything's
starting to sell now so let's hope that
works and we'll see what happens so I
have done a lot of new stuff I bought
some new long bows um I flipped the
mythro bars they've almost sold I'm
still buying RW sharks buying coal
buying yogs and selling those so I
bought these for
682 and I can sell them for
$690 so we'll try selling them for $689
and we'll see if they
sell and then I'm almost done with these
items so then I'll be investing that in
more stuff I'm at 35 minutes and these
have sold these items are slowly buying
I think I'm going to invest in death
runes and undercut them and buy about 6K
of
them I can actually buy more than them
so I'll buy about that many and I will
see what happens so I just flipped these
raw sharks and sold them instantly I
probably should have sold them for more
these death runes are buying a little
too fast I don't know what's going on
there I moved the shark price down I mve
the U Longbow down one GP a little bit
ago and these coal and e- logs are
almost
bought and this gold ore is not selling
anymore so I might have to end up
selling that at the very end cuz I
bought it for 320 so I don't want to
lose money on it yet oh these death
runes just sold let's see how much money
we can sell forth for 368
so let's try
367 and that'll be pretty good margin if
we can get those oh whoops not 367 267 I
was going to say that's a lot of money
anyways I will sell these and then I
will be
back oh wow those actually sold
instantly so never mind I won't leave
those are almost sold these are almost
bought so I'll probably sell those in a
sec so I'll be back so these e logs
bought U logs I keep saying you y logs I
just realized that UL logs I did that in
another video on
accident um this Co bot I'm just going
to go ahead and sell it now so I bought
it for 184 do I have the old prices no
so I'll check these margins and then I
will sell them so I sold a lot of the
coal
instantly and I don't want to sell it
instantly so I decided to move the price
up I did end up selling all these so
that's good money right there I put in
the ye logs for about 3gp profit these
aren't selling still and these aren't
selling so I'm worried I'll have to
instant sell those at the end I hope not
so now we'll find some more items and
try to bust out this last 20 minutes so
this is kind of where I'm at I'm going
to oh I just sold all these finally
thank God I'm trying to buy these I
don't know if they're going to buy I
sold all these finally these are still
not selling I decided to put an offer on
iron knives just in case and I put in
some on some grapes because I know they
sell a lot so we'll see okay so they're
already buying so I can sell those for a
good margin about 10 GP so we'll see if
those go these coal are still selling so
I still have about 15 minutes I don't
want to mess this up because I don't
want to end up instant selling these so
I'll try to invest in probably one more
item and then call it good so I'm at
about 13 minutes so I'm putting in some
off for some Dragon bonees still putting
in the offers for the grapes still
trying to sell the coal so I will and
the Sharks I move them down um I will
probably give it about 5 minutes and
then I will try to sell everything and
we'll see if we can make profit in time
I'm now trying to sell everything with
about 11 minutes left so let's hope all
these sell I'll come back and hopefully
they have been sold I'm really surprised
all those already sold so I'm going to
go ahead and try to get some more dragon
bones real quick before the time runs
out we have about 10 minutes so let's
see what happens so I bought some of the
dragon bones so I'm going to go ahead
and just sell those now while the sharks
are selling and then hopefully we
will make some good profit let's go
ahead and sell these and I'll be back so
we made it there's still about 3 minutes
left but there's no point in buying
other items because I won't have enough
time so let's hope we made a lot of
money let's actually go
here all okay so we made 287k in 1 hour
that's not amazing but a lot of the
items I normally buy like coal and other
bars and other ores weren't selling
right away but if you can sell those you
can make a lot more money but I hope you
guys like this flipping video if you
want to see more of these kind of videos
leave a comment in the comment section
and as always guys thanks for watching
stay tuned for my next video
a